we sleep for 36 percent of our lives but  do we know why well it's a little more  complicated than you think we know that  during sleep muscle growth tissue repair  and protein synthesis occurs so sleep  might restore what the body loses while  we're awake recent studies indicate that  the brain uses sleep in order to flush  out waste toxins in the brain and  problems with this cleaning process may  play a role in many brain disorders such  as Alzheimer's disease another theory  suggests that since new synapses are  constantly being generated throughout  your day sleep you might be when these  synapses are cleaned out while you sleep  your brain might be replaying and  processing the events of your day which  could reinforce learning and memory so  basically what we're saying is we have  no idea why we sleep but we do it for  over a third of our lives we would die  without it